that would be my question I want to send
him big block letters with him 46 font
why please tell me why why my name is
Ingrid Campo and I'm the proud mom of
Mercedes Campbell I got this letter and
the first thing in bold all I saw was
congratulations
and that's when that letter was sent to
inform Ingrid that her daughter Mercedes
was accepted into the DC Opportunity
Scholarship Program also known as the DC
voucher program the program provides
about 1,700 students with 7,500 dollars
per year to use toward tuition for
whatever private school their parents
choose for Ingrid the voucher has been
nothing less than a godsend a chance to
get Mercedes out of one of the most
expensive yet worse performing school
districts in America she now attends
Georgetown visitation a well-regarded
area prep school DC Public Schools have
the worst test scores are some of the
worst test scores in the nation that's
Virginia Walden Ford who's been a leader
in the DC school choice movement for
over a decade ever since her son William
got a scholarship to attend a private
school this is a community that
african-american males just don't do
well and drug dealers and violence just
follows them around I believed in being
able to choose the school that was safe
and a better environment for we and
saved his life both William and Mercedes
were given a chance to attend private
schools through scholarships and
Mercedes is just one of the thousands of
kids who have benefited from the DC
voucher program but working with
congressional Democrats the Obama
administration has effectively killed
the program despite this pledge
secretary Duncan will use only one test
when deciding what ideas to support with
your precious tax dollars it's not
whether an idea is liberal or
conservative but whether it works the
last two evaluations last June and one
most recently came out indicated that
the children are making significant
gains indeed a recent Department of
Education study found that after three
years in private schools students who
came into the DC voucher program when a
first started had a 19-month advantage
in reading over there public school
peers not only that but parents loved
the program so much so that there are
four applicants for every available slot
now Mercedes has grown and blossomed and
matured into a young lady that can make
decisions on her own it's different now
that I go to visit Asia like I
approached things differently we shake a
hole in the world basically I'm just as
bright as the girl who goes who grew up
in all the same and goes to the public
school or Intel or who's been in private
school all her life I think I can
achieve just as much if only I had the
opportunity we need to fight because
this is the only way we're gonna say not
just the present but our kids everything
else that they can shut down
everything's they can advocate for they
want to take this one thing away
overall the DC voucher program costs
about eighteen million dollars a year
that's a good chunk of change but it's
nothing compared to the 67 billion
dollars the feds spent on education last
year and of course that's all in
addition to the trillions of dollars the
government has doled out to prop up
failing banks and auto companies so
let's get this straight the president in
Congress seemed ready to spend countless
gobs of money on any number of failing
businesses but they're unwilling to
spend 18 million dollars for a
successful program to help low-income
families of kids you know the thing that
makes me the angriest about this and I
am angry is that this has become about
politics and not about children you know
it's about parties this party against
this party and it should never be about
politics the argument for school choice
is pretty basic everybody benefits when
they have more options whether we're
talking about cars coffee drinks or
schools that the voucher program spends
half as much per student than the
conventional DC public school is icing
on the cake
what's even more puzzling about Obama's
actions is that he was a scholarship
recipient himself as a youth and he's a
parent who has chosen an elite private
school for his own daughters so he knows
better than most the value of school
choice this is more than just
legislation this is more than just some
paper that we want people to sign these
are kids live
you cannot look at the faces of these
children I can't without thinking about
how this is going to affect them if
Obama fails to live up to his own
rhetoric about doing what's best for
kids not only will if consigned another
generation of students to schools that
will never be fixed
he will availing in some of his most
ardent supporters we voted we walked
wewe went to the parade we stood
freezing why once again goes to a bomb
can I send him that can you get
hash-table but Obama and have him answer
our questions why Sir why
[Music]
you
[Music]